we are often in society told to make
decisions in one of two ways we're
either told use your gut just go with
how you feel about it and let that guide
you or we're told use reason some very
deliberative method methodical process
of pros and cons and really thinking it
through most of the time you should use
reason there's no doubt about that
because gut often makes us up the ball
to lots of different biases particularly
if what you're deciding is something
that you really that expertise can be
brought to bear on it that there really
be there is a way in which you can align
the odds so then you should really his
reason about the only time our gut can
truly outperform our reason is if we
truly have developed a kind of informed
intuition so that means the chess master
I mean someone has really thought about
it and given themselves feedback on a
particular activity for at least 10,000
hours or more the about the only
question that we would say and this is a
big one in our lives that we would say
you don't just use pure reason to decide
the answer to is anything that affects
your happiness because then gut and
reason answer very different questions
so gut tells you how do I feel about
this right now doesn't tell me how I
feel about it tomorrow or even a few
minutes from now it just tells me how
I'm feeling right now reason tells me
when I do the pros and cons analysis how
I should feel about it right now and how
I should feel about it in ten years from
now and so that the only so for
decisions about happiness you
essentially need at least both and
probably even more than that you
probably also need to do analysis that
doesn't involve yourself to get it the
answer of what will make you happy in 10
years